foreign
okay I probably should call it um time
to start okay so next time delighted to
introduce Colin Rafel one of the people
who's actually really built large
language models and knows all the guts
of how they work and there's also set
out on a very
um interesting and rewarding for the
community research program where he's
been very committed to making Research
into this area a community exercise as
you will talk about more
thanks um yeah and I'm really happy to
be here I I'm actually in the middle of
middle of it but when I was invited uh
to speak here I decided I should just
pause everything and come because I
think it's it's a really exciting group
of people and an exciting topic
um and on that note I actually have to
leave right after uh the sessions today
so if uh if people want to follow up on
to to take delivery of my belongings
um so so if people want to follow up on
any of this I won't be around to chat
but I'm obviously happy to chat about
any of this stuff like offline uh and so
at any rate what I'm going to try to do
today is to convince you that the way
that we are building general purpose AI
systems is misguided and I'm going to
try to propose a different way to build
these systems uh that may also be
misguided but at least it's different
and if you think it's misguided say so
and maybe we can talk about it uh but
but at the very least yeah maybe it
presents some new ideas in a new way to
do things so let me get started so
four or so years ago this was the
dominant way to tackle problems in NLP
and lots of other uh application areas
of machine learning we'd start with a
pre-trained model this little Rainbow
neural network in the middle that was
pre-trained on some general task maybe
language modeling or maybe some image
classification tasks with lots of
possible classes and then if we wanted
the model to perform a specific task we
would take the data set that represents
that task and we would fine tune it we
would just train it on that task to
create a specialized model a model that
specialized for that task and hopefully
works pretty well and this is an
incredibly effective Paradigm using
pre-training makes the model merge
converge more quickly to a better
solution typically with less labeled
data so this is just what everyone did
and it was as I said a extremely
effective extremely useful extremely
valuable
um and and these but these days the way
that we attack tasks is often quite
different because we have large language
models and large language models we can
often treat as general purpose systems
that are reasonably competent at
performing lots and lots and lots and
lots of tasks so we train a single model
that hopefully is very good at
performing many many tasks that
generalizes to lots and lots and lots of
tasks that hasn't been trained on and
instead of doing additional training we
just keep the single model fixed and we
ask the model to do what we wanted to do
in the case of a language model in
natural language so you say please
summarize the following article are
these questions asking the same thing
you know what like basically asking
questions making requests and then we
get the language model to do the thing
that we asked and again this is
extremely effective right we have these
giant models we ask them to perform any
task we could possibly think of in
natural language and to a reasonable
extent they actually kind of work and
the larger we make these models the
better they work it's extremely
predictable and so so it has turned out
to be the dominant Paradigm the way kind
of the field is moving towards building
general purpose AI systems
but today I'm going to talk about a
whoops
you know this is strange it's actually
missing a slide uh let me
try to figure out why the slide is
missing
okay so they're supposed oh I should
mention this is the first time I'm
giving this talk
there's and there's a slide missing so
I'll just describe it verbally
um
one thing that we expect when we build
these systems is that these systems get
uh they're we have a reasonably
confident system and if we want the
system to become better we throw it out
and we build a new one from scratch
that's a lot bigger and that new system
is often a lot better and uh and this
approach was exemplified by a comment
made yesterday by yintad I'm sorry to
pick on you but it was the comment was
well we just need to wait for gpt5 right
and so that is exactly what I mean right
if we want a better model we throw out
the old model we build a new one that's
bigger and we get these jumps in in
performance because we've made a jump in
investment in terms of training the
model
and again this has been super effective
but let's talk about a different way
that we might do this okay today we're
going to talk about ecosystems of
specialized models and this Paradigm
doesn't really exist yet but I think it
could work and I'm going to try to
provide you with some evidence that it
might work but let me kind of describe
it as a high level first
so the first thing you'll notice about
this diagram that I made this cartoon is
that everything looks exactly the same
except the box in the middle
so we're still going to be trying to
build general purpose systems that can
perform any task that we throw at it the
difference is that instead of having a
single monolithic model in the middle
that aims to perform everything we're
going to have an ecosystem a collection
of a ton of specialized models and
within this ecosystem
we are going to hope that by combining
the models in different ways we can
perform basically any task that we throw
at
the ecosystem as a whole
and inside this ecosystem might be
thousands of models tens of thousands of
models hundreds of thousands of
specialized models each model can is
really competent let's say at performing
some specific particular task so that's
ingredient one ingredient two is that in
order to treat the ecosystem as a kind
of black box like we do with large
language models
we need a way to automatically select
which specialized models we're going to
use for a particular task so that's kind
of what these little lines represent and
there was a question so I'll stop really
quick
I also hope host different models in
different places different locations
yeah absolutely and actually at the very
end I'll talk a little bit about kind of
like the systems aspect of how you might
like run inference on a system like that
but uh but mostly I'm not going to be
talking about uh I think yeah I think
there are interesting
um possible considerations for like
distributed inference and so on um that
simplify some of these things I'll talk
more generally about efficiency in a
moment
um but yeah that's that's it I think
that would be entirely possible
so yeah so the ingredients are we have
we have hundreds of thousands of of or
thousands or something specialized
models we have automatic routing among
those models
and also I think we probably need a way
to combine models to combine
capabilities because uh senji pointed
out earlier today
in order to perform some particular task
we often need to combine skills so maybe
it's unlikely that we'll have one model
that can you know write poetry in the
style of Tupac about you know
astrophysics or something like that so
maybe we need to combine our poetry
writing model with our Tupac generation
model and our astrophysics knowledge
model or something like that and I'll
discuss that later
but the crucial thing if we are able to
build systems like this is that because
these specialized models often are a lot
cheaper and sometimes are more
performant than the large the large
general purpose monolith model
this entire system could be dramatically
less computationally expensive
and dramatically more or at least
hopefully hopefully more effective but
at the very least as effective as the
monolithic models that we're using today
did you have a question do you yeah uh I
like the ecosystem concept A lot uh just
in terms of potential implementation are
those going to be let's just separated
models like gpd4 flan Etc or are they
going to have one model that's a tailor
or adapted them to different domains
like where do you see the balance there
and also in terms of selection isn't
this kind of downgraded to mixture of
experts to some extent I I will touch on
both of those things
um
on the first later in the talk on the
first question I think this works either
way but there are things some things can
become a little easier if most of them
use the same base model and I'll discuss
that later and I'll also discuss
connections to mixture of experts a bit
later too yeah I have a question so it
looks like this is some sort of Bio
biologically inspired architecture like
simple neurons are sort of a shared
between different uh sub Networks is
that is that the kind of direction that
you're going yeah I I
recognize that I'm using biologically
loaded terms like ecosystem here but I I
do uh biological Concepts is accidental
they're otherwise yeah um I'm not a
biologist uh yeah
I will I will get I will get to that too
so so the missing slide looked like this
except that there were uh orange or
excuse me blue blobs that got bigger as
we went from one system to the next and
we had big jumps and capabilities before
I've used that slide in my past talk so
if you've seen my past talks maybe
you've seen it but for an ecosystem this
is what I think the the
abstract notion of capabilities what the
system can do over time might look like
as the ecosystem grows more models are
introduced recombined uh and and and and
added and removed and so on um and and
and the point that I want to make here
is that if we have an ecosystem that
allows for collaborative development
okay lots of people working together to
add to the ecosystem combine things
together Etc we'll see continual
improvements rather than these big steps
of improvements that result from a
sudden increase in investment okay
so now for the most of the or basically
all of the rest of the talk I'm going to
be talking sketching out how and why
should we build can we build ecosystems
of specialist models instead of
Monolithic models and again this is this
talk is uh mostly speculative I'm going
to try to provide evidence that this
might work a lot of this evidence comes
from other people's work but I'll talk
about my labs work a little bit too
because a lot of it's related and
hopefully by the end of it you'll be at
least a tiny bit convinced that this is
not a completely ridiculous idea
so and I'll make a couple of points
along the way the first point which I
think has already been made pretty well
at this Workshop is that specialist
models are often cheaper and sometimes
better and we had two good examples of
this yesterday in Yin Ted's talk and in
yejin's talk uh the uh the code model
trained on textbook data and the
paraphrasing model both of those were
significantly smaller models that maybe
worked better than the monolithic
generalist model but let me give you a
couple more examples in case you're not
totally convinced uh this first example
I hesitated to include because it's very
out of date because of the monolithic
model we're comparing to is gpt3 which
is you know horribly out of date uh now
um but this is from a paper that we
published last year at nuremps and the
very high level takeaway that this uh
plot is is providing is that if you take
a reasonable pre-trained model and you
fine tune it with a pretty simple and
standardized recipe so it's exactly the
same recipe across every tab every data
set you apply it to
and you take the examples that are used
for in-context learning with gpt3 so
maybe you're doing 32 shotting context
learning with gpt3 and instead of doing
few shotting context running with gpt3
you just use that as a training data set
to fine-tune your model
then the resulting fine-tuned model
works better so it gets higher accuracy
and is dramatically cheaper and the
reason it's dramatically cheaper is
because it's a lot smaller this base
model has 11 billion parameters gbt3 has
up to 175 billion parameters but also a
few shot and context learning is
ridiculously expensive because you have
to process the in context examples
before you make a prediction whereas in
this case after you fine tune it you can
sort of think of it like you're doing
zero shot prediction and it doesn't
doesn't make any sense to say it that
way but the point is you're just feeding
in the query example and getting the
prediction right away yeah
cost
wouldn't you have to consider the cost
of fine tuning in this example so I I'm
yes and no no because once you do fine
tuning you've amortized the cost you
never have to do it again you have your
specialized model you only have to
fine-tune Once in some sense when you do
fusion and context learning you're
processing the data set every time but
even if you consider the cost of fine
tuning fine-tuning this model is about
16 times more expensive than processing
a single example with screenshot and
context learning with gpt3 so by the
time you've done 16 predictions with
gpt3 you could have fine tune your model
you never have to do that again and all
of a sudden your model a thousand times
faster okay so this is a Improvement of
a thousand times of efficiency I know in
NLP we don't ever draw this x-axis
anymore we only draw this y-axis but
this x-axis is very important okay yeah
sorry silly question what's the base
model that you find tuning uh yeah I'm
not going into a ton of detail here
because I'm making a high level point
but this base model is called t0 it's a
uh kind of a multitask variant of T5
it's just that you can just think of it
as like a pre-trained language model
that's like reasonably competent uh in
this case these are the top these are a
subset of tasks that were intentionally
held out from t-zero's training mixture
to cover a range of tasks and I'm not
going to remember all that maybe Sasha
actually remembers the list of tasks but
um NLP they're NLP data sets and it is
important to mention that this again
this is kind of out of date work because
this is pre-chad PPT work it's not about
like open-ended dialogue yeah like
poetry generation Etc it's like nli like
really boring academic stuff
um
okay so one data point okay now let's
try to make it a little bit more up to
date instead of talking about beating
GPT three I'm just gonna quote some
results from the Palm 2 paper so this is
a paper that doesn't even want to
convince you that specialized models can
work well and I'm just going to point
out that they they put these tables in
the paper this is kind of like their
Common Sense reasoning benchmark-ish
table and this is their translation
table
and among the baselines they consider
are specialist models because they're
always quoting the state of the art a by
the way is gpt4 okay so generalist
monolith models sometimes still do win
but for these two data sets in
particular where the Gap is not
insignificant the state of the art is
held by a specialist model and these are
like fine-tuned Bert models okay these
are very cheap effective models
and translation actually they always do
beat Google translate but arguably I
mean it's funny to call Google translate
A specialized specialist model but it
can only perform translation okay so it
is a specialist model and I don't
actually know because we don't know the
system details of Google translate or
Palm to but I suspect that inference
with Google Translate is a lot cheaper
okay and
form two always beats Google translate
which again is conceptually interesting
because it's a general purpose
monolithic model it's not a specialist
model but the Gap is very very small
right so we have a specialist model
that's more efficient that works quite
well again this is this is picking out
of a paper that doesn't even want to
make at this point and again I don't
want to belabor this too much because I
think hopefully at this point you all
can at least Envision that specialized
specialist models can be cheaper and
more effective dropped I think is plus a
calculator right sure yeah and
specialist models can use calculators or
whatever yeah yeah absolutely so
these specialized models have other
disadvantages
the size is good yeah performance in
these cases is good but I understand
that they're brittle if you're attacking
them is easier yeah I don't I think
that's hard to characterize I think I
mean that's a good point I think that's
hard to characterize I think all of
these models are are attackable right
there are especially recently uh
demonstrations of like what you might
call adversarial examples for large
language models not only to do like
jailbreaks but also to do things like uh
getting the model to Output a different
prediction by stating assumptions in a
different way and so on
um I think it's it however I agree that
it's a good point uh to and and it would
be interesting to think about like
as a whole with an ecosystem of
specialized models be more or less
brittle than a generalist model also
some of the work that I'll describe
later on combining the capabilities of
models has been shown to improve
robustness I won't talk about that at
all but I'm happy to provide pointers
offline
cool okay so so yes Baseline specialist
models reasonable place to start okay
so now this is kind of today's point
that this is not necessary this next
point is not necessary but it's a nice
bonus if we want to exploit it which is
that when I talk about a specialist
model I don't necessarily mean like that
we have a hundreds of thousands of
completely different model architectures
uh that are that are share nothing in
common it is also possible to build
specialist models
by making cheaply communicable updates
to a common base model it doesn't mean
we have to do it this way this is just a
nice bonus if we choose to do it this
way
and so to go back to the tview paper
that I was bragging about a moment ago
uh that those results actually come from
not full model fine tuning but what
people call perimeter efficient fine
tuning which is rather than many of you
might be familiar with Laura for example
which is a parameter efficient fine
tuning method or prompt tuning this was
another parameter efficient fine-tuning
method that we came up with that we call
ia3 and the idea with ia3 is that you
take the intermediate activations in the
Transformer and you multiply them
element Wise by a learned vector and the
important bit is that because you're
only introducing a few of these vectors
and not updating all the parameters in
the model you actually update a very
small fraction of the number of
parameters as full model fine tuning
we actually do quite well especially in
the few shots that actually it
outperforms updating all of the models
parameter so it's actually a better way
to fine-tune the model in this case and
it outperforms other parameter efficient
fine tuning methods which is not that
important for the purpose of making this
point the the main point is that the
base model here uh t0
and storing it on disks takes depending
on how you store it let's say tens of
gigabytes storing the ia3 vectors takes
a few megabytes it's not quite small
enough to fit on a floppy disk but it's
it's not far off so you could imagine if
storage I think maybe came up a moment
ago if
I want to store 10 000 specialist models
I only if I if I build my specialist
models by training ia3 vectors it
doesn't cost that much in terms of
storage space and in fact as I'll
discuss briefly later it also makes
things simpler in terms of distributed
inference okay but again you don't have
to do this just a nice bonus if you do
and if you're not familiar people
already are building
giant ecosystems not ecosystems in the
way I'm describing with automatic
recombination of models and routing and
so on but at least big collections of
fine-tuned models via parameter
efficient fine tuning what people often
will call like adapters and so if you go
on the hugging face model Hub and you
look for uh models that have been
uploaded that use PFT the parameter fish
and fine-tuning Library you can see
there are 4 500 of them on adapter Hub
which is another repository there's
about 500 and I didn't include this
example because this is a language model
Workshop but on repositories for
adapters for stable diffusion for
example there are thousands uploaded
every day and these adapters and they're
often based on Laura which again is
another parameter efficient fine tuning
method
they do things like take stable
diffusion and make it so that it always
outputs things that look like cartoons
or it's really good at outputting
backgrounds of a certain kind or
something like that so what is it doing
it's taking a general purpose monolithic
model like stable diffusion and it's
turning them into specialist models okay
so in some sense if we rely on these
model hubs we already have a lot of the
the collection of specialist models that
we might use to build an ecosystem okay
so that's my
second point my third Point important
ingredient that I mentioned earlier
is that if we want to treat the
ecosystem as a replacement for a
generalist model then we need a way to
choose which specialist models will be
used to perform a given query okay
and this will tie into combining models
to combine capabilities but at the very
least we need the way to do this routing
automatically I mean you could imagine
that you rely on the user to choose the
appropriate model but that might be
onerous and it and you know when when I
uh when I use gpt4 I don't have to
scroll through a list of possible
requests and choose one I can use any
request I want and it will perform it so
if we really want to replace generalist
models we need a way to uh to choose a
special a special specialist model
automatically
okay so let me provide you with some
evidence that we might be able to do
this
um the first bit of evidence comes from
a nice
oldish older-ish paper from you know six
or seven years ago on task Quebec
and uh what task direct does is it says
I'm going to represent each data set
by a vector and that Vector is going to
be computed as a kind of a summary of
the diagonal of the Fischer information
Matrix
which sounds like a mess but really what
it's doing is it's measuring what is
this gradient
of the model's output with respect to
the parameters
computed in expectation over the data
set and summarizing that quantity and
using that as a representation of the of
the task
so why might this be a useful way to
represent tasks because if I have two
data sets that change the model in
similar ways that cause the parameters
to be updated in similar ways when you
compute the gradients then those data
sets might be similar they're making the
model do similar things okay and this
paper is mostly focused on image
classification but they find when they
use these tasks to VEC vectors they get
things like you know image
classification tasks having to do with
clothes get clustered in one area the
color causes them to be clustered in a
different area you know different
species go in a different area and this
is kind of clothing tasks and those are
species tasks the details aren't
terribly important except to say that
there is a way to associate with a given
piece of data or chunk of data some
notion of which model is appropriate for
it okay
and I I'm happy for you all to refer to
that paper for more details
what is interesting and as an extra
bonus from using parameter efficient
fine tuning
this nice recent paper showed that if
you just use the values that get dumped
out from parameter fish and fine-tuning
depending on which method you use that's
actually a nice representation of your
task too so remember I said ie3 is uh
you know a few megabytes that's not that
long of a vector if you stack all the
vectors up if I compare the ia3 vector
from one task to the ie3 vector for
another task their similarity actually
represents reasonable motions of task
similarity okay
so so again we kind of for free get away
of of of associating data with a
particular appropriate model
now
the last point I'll make about routing
among specialized models is the exactly
the point that they made earlier which
is that we actually already have an
example of a model architecture that
does automatic routing among specialized
networks in this case we call them
experts and in this case they are
actually kind of sub layers in a larger
model but a mixture of expert style
model can be thought of as a model that
has a router that takes as input some
intermediate activations in the model
and adaptively selects which sub network
to use to send those activations to
so this is not an ecosystem of models so
much as maybe an ecosystem of sub models
like of layers but these These are quite
effective and I'll talk in a few slides
about a mixture of expert style
architecture that exhibits the kind of
behavior that I that I I think is
desirable for these ecosystems okay
so hopefully some evidence that
specialized Network expert selection
might work
okay so now some of you might be
thinking great you maybe you can give me
a big collection of specialized models
and you can give me a way to choose
which specialized model I should use for
a given query but what if
again I have a task that is the that
requires lots of different skills right
and so I'm really glad we already had
the discussion about how tasks can be
considered as a composition of skills
and Sanjeev has definitively convinced
all of you that that we can think of
things this way and also if they're
exactly a thousand skills
um but I'll make the same point that the
Synergy made earlier today which is that
at least conceptually we can think of a
given task that we might want to perform
as a composition of skills so we might
say you know let's say for this query
how long would it take for a penny to
hit the ground from the top of the
Empire State Building that requires
maybe physical reasoning World Knowledge
arithmetic and a lot of these skills uh
like World Knowledge for example if you
buy that that's an actual skill
um Can can also be encapsulated in tasks
that focus on that one particular skill
so let's say for let's assume that among
our many thousands of specialized models
we often have a specialized model that
can perform some particular skill now
the question becomes do we have a way to
combine capabilities of models right
because if again Sanji made this had
this nice argument earlier that one of
the benefits of scale is increasing the
capability of doing compositional kind
of like a compositional generalization
of of combining more skills so we can go
from combining you know three skills to
four skills as we scale up and so on
that's incredibly useful capability of
these monolithic models if we want our
ecosystem to have the same capability we
need a way to combine specialist models
to compositionally combine skills okay
what might that look like well I'm going
to call that this this action of taking
specialized models and combining them to
create a composite model that can
perform the individual tasks of the the
specialized models I'm going to call
that merging merging models and maybe
the reason that I chose that terminology
will become clear later but it's also
common terminology in the field and the
important thing about merging is that if
we could do this it would enable New
Paths for transferring capabilities
across models because typically if we
want a model to have some particular
capability then we perform some training
right in in olden days and transfer
learning we would perform fine-tuning on
a data set that represent that
particular task currently we just scale
up and we hope that the model learns
that task in the data somewhere and then
can compose it with other tasks
but if we had an operation
that again I'll call merging what that
would allow us to do is take for example
two specialized models and combine them
to create a composite model that could
perform uh you know both of the tasks of
the models that are being combined and
it also allows for more unusual ways of
combining models right if you imagine in
our ecosystem we have a model that's
derived from you know this path of
sequential gradient Based training and
then we take the original model and
train it on some other data set then we
could merge these models and get some
kind of new composite model okay so
that's what merging might enable us to
do and I'm going to use the word merging
kind of as a generic term to describe a
few different methods so I'll mention in
a moment yes I should think of each
circle as one of your adapter models as
some specialize
parameters exactly and but again and
most of the methods that I'll describe
assume that the model architecture among
the models being merged is uh uniform
it's consistent so they have the same
architecture the one-to-one
correspondence between parameters
um you could imagine merging methods
that make this assumption but all of
them all of them will and they don't
have to be parameter efficient they
could just be fine-tuned models too but
but for the purpose of kind of what I
think is the most plausible path towards
this sure we can think of them as
parameter efficient methods too
and to give you an example of one
something that I think looks like
merging that has been shown to work okay
that shows this ability this like
compositional generalization ability
comes from this nice paper overcoming
catastrophic for getting in zero shot
cross single General generation
where they show that if you train via
one particular form of parameter
efficient fine-tuning called prompt
tuning if you train parameter efficient
adapters learned prompts
for languages and tasks then you can
compose those prompt vectors and
generalize to new combat new language
task combinations right so I train my
language model on a bunch of Vietnamese
data and I only update the parameters of
this adapter this prompt
uh this learned prompt via this
parameter efficient fine tuning method I
take the same language model and I train
it on a variety of tasks in the same way
and if I want my model to perform task 2
in Vietnamese I just concatenate those
two prompt vectors and I get a model
that performs the task in Vietnamese
reasonably well okay so this this works
okay it's an interesting paper
another example task Vector so this is a
this is a such a fun idea
um because it's it's so simple and it
works surprisingly well
if I take my pre-trained model perform
some fine tuning and then I take the
fine tune parameter values and I
subtract the pre-trained values so I'm
getting a vector that represents the
movement in parameter space that my
model underwent when I fine-tuned it I'm
going to call that my task vector now I
can do all kinds of weird things with
these task vectors like for example I
can take a language model train it on a
bunch of toxic text
go from here to here compute the task
vector and then negate it and subtract
it from the pre-trained model the
language model will generate less toxic
tasks very interesting
if I want to compose tasks which is the
thing that we really care about I mean
this is very cool but it's not exactly
what we're talking about today if I want
the model to compose tasks I take the
task Vector for two tasks and I add them
together
and now I have a multitask model
and this works pretty well okay
so again another example if I have these
specialized models that correspond to
this this point in this point and I want
to get a multitask model that can
perform the tasks that the individual
models can perform on their own and just
add up their task vectors right this is
this requires no additional training
okay so it could be done adaptively for
any input query
let's let's go a little maybe I'll try
to surprise you even a little more if
you're not surprised yet
um maybe you won't be surprised at all
uh so they aren't necessarily small but
they and I didn't mention this work in
in this talk they turn out to be low
rank or have like a low intrinsic
Dimension right
um and uh and one of the weird things
about
neural networks and gradient-based
training is that as you train neural
networks for longer and longer even as
your loss plateaus to its minimum value
the parameter values often continue to
grow and shrink and change you can kind
of think of like the model is orbiting a
region in in parameter space where the
loss is all low there are also these
funnies uh symmetries that neural
networks have like if I scale up the
weight in one layer and scale down the
weight and the other layer uh the
network computes the same function so
you know I can make them have huge
values right the actual magnitude of the
task Vector can be very big but in
practice they're like for example
they're uh they have a low intrinsic
dimensionality
um
um the arithmetic of like NLP tasks is
fun yeah but like now that we have
language that can describe like very
complex combinations and compositions it
feels like a much richer surface than it
did in like the word to back times yeah
and I'm curious like why not just use
language I mean we have OMS yeah so so I
don't actually
um
I don't have a slide for this that
represents existing work but one of the
things that I think would be really cool
to do would be to build a joint
embedding space of task instructions
data sets and models right so let's say
I have a bunch of specialized models I
want a way to go from description of the
task that the model performs to a vector
that is close to that model's Vector
right so and or I have some examples of
the task but maybe I'm asking a
different question which is like all
this stuff assumes a sort of linearity
that we don't have to assume nor are
people naturally assuming when they
describe tasks it's linearity in terms
of like you have this like metric space
of tasks or something that just feels to
me like unnecessary if you can just
describe what you're looking for but
maybe I'm missing something well
I wouldn't say that the linearity of
task combinations is a requirement for
any of this to work I'm mostly saying
that interestingly that's what actually
just happens when you train models and
we can exploit that to do things like
combine the capability like the skills
of different individual models okay yeah
um
I just want to follow up on the betrays
ability and worry about that one and
whether or not this generalizes
something that isn't metric and was
affine and do you like have examples of
where you know instead of like dealing
with a vector you're dealing with
something yeah
to my knowledge there hasn't I mean this
the task Factor paper is relatively
recent and I think this is an example of
something that's incredibly simple and
works surprisingly well but probably
isn't sufficient maybe that answers your
question too right
um and actually what I'll describe after
I show you that people are merging
models already and it works reasonably
well is some of the work in my group on
doing more sophisticated merging methods
that aren't just adding task vectors
together
so maybe that will help uh answer those
questions
so the last thing I'll say and again
maybe this will surprise you maybe it
won't
this recent paper showed that it was
possible to take a shared Transformer
backbone train a text Transformer and a
vision Transformer merge them and you
get a multimodal Model A model that has
a shared representation space for tax
for text and images that can you know
enable you to perform this standard like
uh image and language tasks and it turns
out that this works okay whether you
just average together the parameters of
the model whether you do a task Vector
arithmetic what they call modality
arithmetic or you do more sophisticated
things and this works okay it's not
perfect but as a proof of concept it
exists
so certainly people would think that
processing images and processing text
involve different skills and here are
some skills that you can combine and get
a composite model
cheaply
and in fact
I've mentioned kind of these Community
these Community Collections of
specialized models people are already
merging these models to create composite
models that inherit the abilities of the
individual models and here's an example
of a language model on hugging face that
is described as being composed in this
way and I don't actually understand this
syntax they don't Define the syntax at
all but the syntax involves taking
individual models in this case uh
Laura's so parameter efficient updates
and adding them together in different
ways to for example make it so that the
model is better at following
Instructions make it so that the model
you know doesn't forget its World
Knowledge
etc etc and again I'm not including
stable diffusion examples here but this
is even more common in the stable
diffusion community so for example
earlier I was mentioning I might have
like a a Laura a parameter efficient
fine-tuning update and adapter for
stable diffusion that makes cartoon-like
images another one that makes uh synth
Punk backgrounds another one that makes
people with really nice beards
and I can combine those adapters and
make a model a stable diffusion variant
that is very good at making images of
that kind composed of those
characteristics so this is already super
common so proof of concept it works
so now let me just talk a little bit
about maybe addressing these questions a
little bit but like
probably
just saying that we're going to do this
by adding things together and averaging
things is is probably insufficient when
we want to do sophisticated things so
I'll talk about two pieces of work uh
done by my lab and some collaborators on
more sophisticated ways of merging
models
this first work
uh kind of formalizes model merging as
an optimization problem so if we
formalize it in this way we say that
we're going to try to find the parameter
value that maximizes this objective but
this objective is is a sum of the
posterior for each individual model that
we're being that is being merged and
this hyper parameter Lambda sub I is
just a you know model specific hyper
parameter that we can tune or you can
just assume that it's 1 over M if we're
waiting each model equivalently
but the difficult thing with formalizing
it in this way is that we don't actually
have access to the posterior of our
neural networks when we train them with
maximum likelihood we just have a point
estimate
and so in the work that I'm describing
we use the LaPlace approximation uh for
those who aren't familiar we're
essentially taking a second order Taylor
expansion of the posterior around a mode
around the parameter value found via
maximum likelihood training and that
corresponds to assuming that the
parameter values are gaussian
distributed with a mean at the uh
parameter values found during maximum
like bid training and uh and a Precision
Matrix as is has the Hessian but we
can't really compute the Hessian for
these large neural networks so we use
the Fischer information which core which
is very close to the Hessian atom mode
of the posterior we can't compute the
fissure either so we use the diagonal
fissure these are sort of unimportant
details the important bit is that if we
make this approximation to the model's
posterior distributions we can solve
this maximization problem in closed form
and we get this closed form solution to
the model parameters here but we're
actually basically doing is Computing a
weighted average of the model's
parameters where the weighting is done
by the Fischer information value so
basically we're up waiting parameters
that are important to a given model and
downloading parameters that aren't
so if we do this I'm just going to throw
one example out there we have lots of
other experiments in the paper but if we
do this we can do that kind of esoteric
merging pattern I described earlier and
we can for example take an RTE model
that underwent intermediate task
training with mnli which is a well-known
performant recipe merge it with donor
tasks and get a boost in performance
over the original model so it's not just
for combining capabilities we also can
can boost the performance of a model on
a specific task by performing merging
now I'll describe one other piece of
work on performing on performing merging
in a little bit more sophisticated way
this one doesn't have the same kind of
uh arguably principled underpinnings it
was just kind of found heuristically but
what we're doing here is we're saying
for a given model maybe there are
certain parameters that are especially
important maybe some of them aren't if
we just average together things that
aren't important to one model with those
that are important to another model
maybe it'll wash out the changes to one
of the models so the first step we're
going to do is we're going to remove all
of the if you assume we have a task
Vector we're going to set all of the
values in the task Vector to zero if
they're small so if the parameter hasn't
changed that much
and then we're going to resolve
differences in sine in terms of which
way the parameter values Changed by
having the models essentially vote as to
what the final sign should be and then
we're only going to average together
parameter values whose sine agrees with
this uh with with this aggregated sign
and again this was found heuristically
we don't have any good justification of
why it works but it does actually help
so if you focus on the application that
really I'm talking about now which is
basically merging together models that
are individual test models to get a
multitask model it works significantly
better than simple averaging which is
what most people use but also better
than task Vector arithmetic and one of
the nice things is that this is the
normalized performance with respect to
the individual task models you can see
them when we merge together two or even
three models we basically don't
sacrifice any performance so we we are
really retaining these individual
capabilities
and the last piece of work I'll describe
on combining capabilities of different
sub models
use is more of a mixture of expert style
framing so in this case we actually are
assuming that rather than combining
specialized entire models we're just
combining specialized experts and what
we're going to do is rather than routing
discreetly among some particular expert
we're going to take the distribution
over the experts and computer weighted
average of those experts we're
essentially going to merge them and if
we do that and train on a multitask
mixture in this case the data sets from
glue you a a nice kind of at least
somewhat intuitive pattern emerges which
is basically that tasks that share
something in common often share experts
tasks that don't get their own expert
and tasks that require lots of different
capabilities often use lots of experts
like mnli which is a kind of a broad
domain data set
so hopefully this convinces you yes go
ahead
it's the symbol point but uh I missed it
do you do the merging per prom for
example or is it given for tasks that
you want to combine you make a model
that
combines though yeah so I um I haven't
really bridged the part of the talk
where I was talking about choosing Which
models to use with this part of the talk
which corresponds to combining
capabilities however
because that work doesn't exist yet but
the hope is that by combining work that
allows you to select Which models to use
with work so let's say let's say that
you have an intelligent routing based on
task vectors or something else and you
feed in your example and it says you
should use these five models
merging provides you with a way to
immediately completely combine those
models and get a composite model that uh
kind of inherits the capabilities of
those individual models that no one has
actually done this but I think given
some of this past work that might
actually work
environmentally compared
of
um your metal Eco system method and
putting all data together using
instructive learning
yeah so
no partially because an ecosystem like
the one I'm describing just has doesn't
exist it hasn't been built yet
um
the closest thing that's been that I
think maybe answers your question is can
I take
you know K data sets train K specialized
models and merge them and get a model
that works about as well as multitask
training on those K data sets I think
that's is that roughly correspond to
what you're asking
definitely
um
yeah and this
um these need to be probably compared
okay different tasks absolutely and and
to kind of finish the the direction I
was going P people have shown that
merging provides the same kind of uh
positive interference kind of benefits
like you're describing right if I have
two data sets or two tasks that have
things in common then merging those
models can boost the performance on one
of the tasks just like you know doing
multitask training on languages that
have something in common could boost the
performance in the low resource language
people have shown that but generally it
doesn't work quite as well as multitask
learning at this point
is that answer your question
so it in I don't know of any work in the
language case but certainly in the
multitask case yeah this is this is a
common
ly we have some experimental result yeah
yeah most of the papers I described
include this exact setting which is uh
you know comparing training on K data
sets at once like multitask learning
multilingual learning versus training on
them separately and then merging them
and like I said it doesn't typically
doesn't work quite as well but it's
pretty close
yeah
great
oh and I should mention at this point
just throw out a a note that again
merging also and I'm not discussing any
of this work today merging also has been
shown as a way to improve robustness and
out of domain generalization
Okay so
the last note and this goes back to an
earlier question is
in order to build an ecosystem like this
it's probably helpful to
use to build systems that make this kind
of collaboration and make running
inference and doing all of these
operations easier
and we've actually built some of these
systems uh and I'll describe two of them
now
um the first one is called git Theta and
the idea would get Theta is that we're
going to just replicate the exact
workflow that people already use for
version controlling source code
with model checkpoints and so what does
it mean
to replicate that workflow it means that
we are going to be able to perform the
exact same git commands
to track changes to a model checkpoint
and also merge model checkpoints so this
is where the term merging comes from
um and so this is a kind of a pseudocode
example of a of of this pipeline for
model development we start by telling
git Theta that we want to track the
original checkpoint we just commit the
model as usual we perform a made-up
fine-tuning step and then we commit the
new model now we check out a new branch
called RTE we do some fine tuning here
we check out the main branch do some
fine tuning there and then just run git
merge RTE to tell git Theta that we want
to merge the RTE Branch with the main
branch
we perform the merge it gives us various
ways to perform merging representing
some of the methods that I described
earlier commit it and then do some other
operations to the model
and so git Theta Works reasonably well
it's on GitHub and actually as long as
your git remote supports git lfs which
GitHub does the hug and face model Hub
does
you can use git Theta natively with that
remote
so then
how do we characterize the benefit of
using git data well you could imagine
that rather than using get Theta you
just use git lfs to track the checkpoint
at every uh at every point in in the
Version Control pipeline in that case
you wouldn't be able to do a merge and
you could ask for example how much space
do we save versus just saving you know
one two three four five six copies of
the model checkpoint and that's what
this graph shows you it shows you that
if you do parameter efficient fine
tuning which we did in this made up
example you would save a lot of disk
space and also if you do something like
we did in this operation which just
corresponded to removing some of the
model's parameters you also save a ton
of space and actually you save a little
bit of space even if you do a dense
update if you update the model's
parameters just because of the way get
Theta compresses the checkpoint
and you know in this example if you
actually do this pipeline you can see
that the model's performance gets better
over time on the tasks that we're
discussing um so you know get Theta
works for a somewhat real world example
okay so we can track the provenance of
the model ecosystem if someone gives the
model ecosystem a new model and we
improve that model in some way or merge
it with another model we can use git
Theta to track that in a principled way
instead of just having a big mess of
models
and now finally we'll get to the
question that I think came up earlier
which is basically how would you do
distributed inference in this case I
think
in general it would make distributed
inference simpler we haven't built the
system that says that many peers are
going to be serving specialized models
and we're going to be routing things
appropriately but we have built a system
that makes it easy to do distributed
inference of a single largest model
and what this system does is it takes
the layers of the model chops them up
into groups and then peers can volunteer
and say I'm going to run inference with
these layers it then compresses the the
layers to make inference fast and then
it compresses the activation so that
when they're sent to the next peer over
the Internet because this is all done in
a totally distributed way on volunteer
Computing over the Internet the
communication costs aren't terribly High
also does intelligent routing to decide
which peers should be used to make some
particular request and it works
reasonably well it's a it's a decent way
of Performing volunteer inference and in
fact you can use pedals which is what
the system is called right now to do
inference on various models so here's
the health dashboard which is basically
showing for a given checkpoint do we
have peers that are willing to serve
blocks of the models layer
um and one crucial thing which I don't
have a nice slide or diagram for is that
pedals natively supports hot swapping uh
adapters parameter efficient fine tuning
vectors so if I have you know the stable
Beluga base model and I make a
specialized model and I want to run
inference with that specialized model I
can just pass pedals the adapter and it
will run inference using that adapter it
also does a fine tuning of adapters in
the same way so so you know so these
monolith models these generalist models
work really well by being served by a
company with access to a expensive
supercomputer
systems like pedals would make it
possible to do inference of an ecosystem
on volunteer Computing so we don't have
to rely on a centralized supercomputer
or company
so
that's all I'm going to say today
whenever I give talks I put this URL on
my last slide which is a way to give me
Anonymous talk feedback if you thought
I'd talk too quickly too slowly covered
too much too little whatever you can
give me feedback there and also like I
said I have to leave so if you want to
follow up with me after the questions
are done there's my email and happy to
hear from any of you
foreign
so thanks for the great talk um so what
I have a question which is I think the
word ecosystem is a bit overloaded in
the sense that there are two type of
ecosystem where you have like you have
an ecosystem of models or you have an
ecosystem of different people and the
ownership is distributed I think we have
argued that like we can have an
ecosystem of different models which is
more economically efficient but we can
imagine that one single company can just
choose this particular architecture of
having an ecosystem or model so in that
sense the ownership is still monolithic
yeah so uh what do you think about the
comparative advantage of the community
to build this type of ecosystem
advantage over a single company building
this equal ecosystem models yeah
absolutely yeah and it's entirely true
that you could imagine this ecosystem
being built by a single entity
um and by the way I'm not great with
branding so if anyone has a better word
than ecosystem I'm open to it
um but uh but yeah to your point I do
think that one of I mean I didn't
mention this as a as a point of
motivation but I I I worry a lot about a
future where the kind of these this very
powerful very useful technology which
are these kind of like generalist AI
systems are controlled by uh relatively
small group of Institutions or entities
uh that are uh very resource rich and
also profit motivated
um I I I I don't know how much detail I
need to go into it's a gut feeling but
that's just how I feel
um and and so and I think generally when
you
when you distribute uh Power when you
distribute responsibility
um things usually go better and I do
think that this uh this system or this
approach provides a way to decentralize
power
thank you for the great talk so a
question about the models that you
envision in these ecosystems in the
future are you sort of leaning more
towards um ecosystems of many sort of
many many models some of which might be
very redundant or sort of the way to go
or something where you're going for like
a really small set a very diverse almost
orthogonal models
give more position yeah I think that's
an interesting point and it's it's not
something I brought up but but you
absolutely could imagine uh kind of
pruning the ecosystem right like if you
have a bunch of redundant models maybe
you can combine those models into a
single aggregate model and make sure
that it kind of retains the capabilities
of the individual models and the
performance and make the ecosystem
smaller um I do think a lot of the stuff
I described today is pretty scalable
though right like again if you use
parameter efficient fine-tuning the
storage requirements are not a huge
issue I think most of the methods that
like you could use for choosing which
specialized model to use you can imagine
doing that pretty effectively just by
Computing dot products of you know model
vectors so I think it is pretty scalable
but I I uh I agree that it would totally
make sense to think about how to like
prune out models and so on yeah
so great great talk um
I'm wondering about the counterpart of
bit rot in this world right so into
specifically suppose you think that
you had this ecosystem sort of set up
around gpt2 right and then a bunch of
like thousands of things have emerged
people are combining them getting lots
of things to work and then someone
invests and trains gpd3 right okay now
what yeah yeah so so I do think again if
if you think of the general case where
the individual models in the ecosystem
don't have to have anything in common
they don't have to have a base model you
could have an ecosystem that has gpt3
based models and gbt2 based models most
of the merging methods I described would
not really work in that setting you
could imagine maybe doing an intelligent
thing where you only use these merging
methods on like compatible models or
something like that
um and I didn't talk about this as
future work but I do think it's valuable
to start thinking about how to uh how to
merge models that don't have
architectures in common for example but
I I think in the and again this goes
back to today's question that she threw
out right away which is uh which is
basically like does this work when the
models are not the same and totally does
I just think there's there are benefits
to what it when it does
um and it also kind of goes back to this
other question of like how do you prune
models that maybe aren't working as well
or are some like a predose of optimal or
something like that
yeah so uh you mentioned that this could
be kind of like a paid system and people
get reimbursed or something but it's not
clear how you attributes
the the benefit of yeah individual
models I don't know if I said that I I
may have I might have I I believe you
more than I believe my my own memory but
but I I do I mean actually for for just
to make a specific example in petals we
thought about a way ways to incentivize
peers for example because these peers
are doing our volunteer Computing
they're basically offering up their gpus
for free
um you know the simplest thing to do is
to say you know if we have a distributed
Cloud you get Priority Access by
volunteering your compute uh you could
imagine similar incentives to say you
know those whose models are used more
often maybe get prioritized inference or
something like that but
I I don't have any concrete examples of
what might work because you know it
doesn't really exist yet yeah
question um I think in most of the work
on merging the user needs to specify
what's merged and yeah and how is that
right um is this a work on automating
this as like a search process yeah in
the space of um specialized models to
merge yeah and I
didn't make Express
that there is a interesting intersection
of the uh kind of model routing like
appropriate model selection work and the
model merging work and certainly there
has been work again that has shown that
if I have models trained on tasks that
are similar to The tasks that I want the
my model to eventually perform if I
merge those models I get a boost in
performance on the target task like that
that is a thing that works and again I
think if you have a sophisticated way of
identifying Which models have been
trained on similar tasks then I think
you get the the kind of benefit you're
describing yeah okay today rather than
panels and receptions we have another
talk so I think maybe we should think
color to move on
[Applause]
yeah
foreign